comme la Présidente Mesdames et
Messieurs les députés dans la continuité
de la réponse qui a été formulée par
Gérald Darmanin ou complétez la réponse
d'abord nous partageons votre
indignation comme nous partageons
l'indignation et je crois c'était ce que
vous avez dit aussi de tous ceux qui
sont victimes de violence violent
physique c'est le cas de Paul François
violence verbale parfois violence sur
les biens et les outils de travail
parfois aussi donc on a on a besoin de
se mettre d'accord sur l'idée que nous
dénonçons toutes les violences Gérald
Darmanin a annoncé aussi à d'indiquer
aussi que les moyens de police sont à
disposition que la justice est saisie de
grief très graves séquestration violence
en réunion et puis la gestion de
produits dont on ne sait pas encore la
nature mais enfin tout ça a été la
comment dirais-je la justice est saisie
et donc comme pour toutes les enquêtes
comme tous les pour les tous les faits
de violence il y a pas de tri
et donc pour lui comme pour les autres
diligence sera faite par les moyens de
police et par les moyens de justice pour
faire en sorte que personne ne puisse
être intimidé violenté à raison de ses
opinions et je pense à tous ceux dans le
monde agricole ou en dehors du monde
agricole qui a raison de ce qu'ils font
parfois dans le monde agricole c'est
simplement pour leur activité qu'ils
sont violentés ici c'est peut-être et
sans doute parce que le pour les combats
qu'il a mené mais moi j'entends bien
défendre l'ensemble des agriculteurs qui
sont victimes de violence verbale de
violences physiques ce qui est la
gradation supplémentaire et donc la
justice et la police seront au
rendez-vous pour faire en sorte la
gendarmerie en l'occurrence pour faire
en sorte qu'il soit donné droit à la
requête de la justice de trouver les
coupables des agissements pour que ce
soit le François comme sur tous les
autres je vous remercie monsieur le
ministre monsieur
merci monsieur le ministre pour votre
réponse j'insiste sur la la gravité de
ce qu'a vécu Paul François au-delà de
l'épreuve personnelle ce qui se joue
c'est la possibilité pour des milliers
de militants de pouvoir continuer à
lutter pour le bien commun et ceci en
toute sécurité c'est à l'État au
gouvernement de garantir cela et c'est
votre responsabilité
[Applaudissements]
oui monsieur le député c'est notre
responsabilité c'est ce que nous faisons
pour toutes les personnes qui sont
menacées parfois des parlementaires ici
des responsables syndicaux là des
agriculteurs et nous le faisons à toute
voie et moyens parce qu'il n'y a pas de
démocratie si ce répand et se construit
en permanence quelque chose qui est de
l'ordre de la violence verbale et de la
violence physique beaucoup plus grave
encore merci je vous remercie monsieur
le min